[Music]
he's gonna learn today news you gonna
learn today
flirting guys no she's covered in hair
I'm chastising who are you guys buying
gel sizing me stop being laying here
yeah what are you gonna do punished okay
now submitted by Jerry from nm New
Mexico Oh New Mexico that's where our
aliens are and I'm all the places I
believe that New Mexico are you joking
cuz I believe that no I believe it we're
good thank you they have beautiful
sunsets I just want to make sure that
I'm not being mainly and we should not
be made for now thank you
Walter White no area 51 is Nevada uh
Roswell is New Mexico remember that show
Roswell there was a cute girl on it the
whole town of Roswell is just a memory
she's [ __ ] aliens I remember like a
naked teen guy make a team guy here's
the lead right maybe there was a blonde
girl I was cute poor know what you guys
walk in and start [ __ ] I'm right I
think I like that show Roswell New
Mexico a mother catches and whips her 13
year old son who stole her BMW to visit
his girlfriend oh that makes it what
whips catches and whip yeah I hope it's
like with the medieval war no it's with
the theme thought fountain it's the dog
so I [ __ ] so they're Mexican whenever
I got beat dude I would pray I would get
the belt the belt was so much easier to
take than the [ __ ] stick in the bat
in the middle pipe that's [ __ ] up your
parents hit you with objects I just got
another list you parenting you with
object closed fist you got hit with
objects from the game Clue yeah
basically Mesa claims Jesus de la bra
yeah
and what's it called the [ __ ] Jewish
little cattle thing Oh menorah yeah
alright so this takes place in El Paso
and so his sister tweeted this out
fossil excess Becca it started with this
tweet my 13 year old brother
disconnected the Wi-Fi so my mom
wouldn't be able to see her cameras and
took her brand-new BMW to his
girlfriend's house I shouldn't be
laughing but damn she tweeted that she
tweeted that and then she also tweeted
first stop his girlfriend's house
[Music]
pictures juicy she made me bring a bell
to propose to this was rich yeah I hope
she holds it on the buckle Hermes I hope
she holds the buckle dad will be
forgiving him for stealing her whip
that's a good pun yeah thank you kind of
fun not the dark lip thank you the whip
you're supposed to use the belt buckle
at the end there right wrap around you
yes dude how can you be driving that
kind of car with that kind of bag and
then you have like a [ __ ] curtain
little water in there yes you pronounced
it baby
yeah it's a fight I want white oh yeah
baby I love a man me salmon Mario
parties it's a French product so how do
you say Avion in in France oh yeah we
all you have the whispering foods really
exactly right yeah I'm gay
no so scheana did a Q&A video later I
just went viral with her brothers she
was saying like they're not rich it's
just like her dad works in buying
auction cars and like flipping them and
then reselling them wait that doesn't
mean you're not rich no that's
for the Cadillac and then the Louis
Vuitton she bought it from like a
verified reseller so she bought it like
not even to a secondhand yeah like for
sure let's go buy coach it was given to
her dad from her like her uncle or
something they don't even know that that
brand but the way they're using that
belt to beat somebody no they don't know
they didn't know that that belt was like
they saw an agent day like this yeah
they just didn't know anyway moving over
Matt I love that they got a should tell
everyone how not reached their right way
but they buy those products to look
great a gift a gift but the car do we
have a Tom bag like I would never buy a
Louboutin because I don't really know
designers at all and so like you know if
they're like how pride in that sort of
thing I got a little bit Tom wallet
image I mean they're Mexican Mexicans
like we're very materialistic people and
same with Filipinos so bought me a
name-brand wallet I remember my aunt got
me a coach keychain and I thought it was
from a sports store his coach thought it
was like a whistle blowing coach I got
sport for a peasant brand stuff she's
like hey don't worry we're not rich my
dad just makes money buying and flipping
companies yeah that doesn't mean you're
not rich do so that BMWs she calls it a
brand like her new BMW but it's not like
brand new off the lot it's like brand
new to them hey some people don't even
have that kind of money that's why
they're considered rich in a lot of
people's eyes yeah but not as rich as
other people anyway the book yes they're
not real wealthy but they have enough
money to buy nice things yes
so let me show you upper-middle class
yeah she ended up recording her mom I
finally found the BMW on this street
here we go oh yeah and it's raining -
that boy should have been driving in the
rain exactly
even more men was because of the ring
you barely see a good driver adults
can't even [ __ ] Drive kron4 News
Kendra let's do it I'm proud of him that
he can actually drive though I would too
though I wouldn't whip him but I would
me as a mom
music mom you want to be you as a mom
you now you [ __ ] up
I'll be laughing to get away with
stealing a car you know as a sibling
there is nothing more fun than watching
the sibling get destroyed over something
and knowing that you're completely like
innocent innocent and it's like wearing
it like an involve building shield
because you're the favorite one at the
moment
the older sister Shirdi has like her own
kid like next door so it's not like as
close in age as you think but it's still
funny yeah all smug about it it's so fun
I love the smug to tune like wow I think
a hundred percent we should have done it
definitely put on a [ __ ] boxing glove
and start whaling on my kid like as hard
as [ __ ] possible like I would try to
break something on him you know I'd be
sick I'd be scared that if I Drive up to
my kid that they're gonna try to race me
and drive off oh that's what no dude
this kid I'm like [ __ ] pull over door
like Oh scared enough of you yeah
exactly
that's some [ __ ] you would do most kids
wouldn't do that if I saw my parents
yeah I would drive up I would try to get
you're gonna get caught eventually and
it's gonna be
I'll Drive away and then I won't go home
for three days and let them chill out Oh
lay low
well I dare you if I was you or my kid
no chill here for three days
oh yeah I could let it stew I'll call
the cops cuz she was scared because I
was avoiding her like crazy cuz I took
the car to once when I was thanks 15/16
and yeah like she they call the cops and
like all my friends were like you need
to get in contact with your mom cuz
she's calling all of us and the cops are
getting involved like you really need to
go home or like call her or something I
finally called her like mom okay okay
hung up that was just so scared but then
finally I ended up going home and if I
tell I got home there was no door am I
in my room she's like you're not getting
privacy anymore
did you put up some beads you don't be
what do they like hanging me my
grandmother yeah Durell arias so this
dude this kid it was the second time he
took oh [ __ ] yeah the first time the mom
was just like that's it I [ __ ] had it
because the first time they handle I
guess she didn't whip him or I don't
know what happened but like she talked
to him for a long time and like you know
she thought she got through to this kid
like you shouldn't be taking the car but
that [ __ ] game is so strong for a 13
year old lost in the sauce yeah so then
now that's why she had the belt I would
almost want my kid to steal some [ __ ]
just with a [ __ ] mop David you Davey
do have too many childhood issues
lots of kids I could [ __ ] him up I would
leave the keys out right next to the
[ __ ] door I'll pretend to sleep like
in deep sleep these are the people
though that once they do have kids like
they're just [ __ ] you're just gonna
be a giant [ __ ] be surprised you'll be
like Bart with Tiger oh yeah he was the
meanest uncle he was so mean to us and
then and he'd be like are you kids and
then and he was the oldest uncle and
then he had a kid and he babies the [ __ ]
out of that kid yeah probably but in my
mind right now I don't have a kid so as
of right now I would love for that [ __ ]
that happen these are perfectly normal
feelings yeah little [ __ ] [ __ ]
what if they pull of Charlotte and they
want to legally leave the fam the
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here I like
that usual the Noah's Ark reference
Charlotte god forbid David so can't have
kids and has to adopt that's right there
is so much footage you saying you'd beat
the [ __ ] out of your kids stop James
it would just melt you you have to
change your name and appearance and
everything new it up no no [ __ ] kids
you could do it in Korea let's give it
to me so if you had a kid and they were
mad at you they could just lie and say
that you beat the [ __ ] out
I always say if you lie about a crime
then it should really happen to you yeah
it's like okay well fine if you're gonna
get taken away from me beating the [ __ ]
out of you I'm as what you do it for
real in it right so cool
so in between that time there's about 15
minutes before the cops come I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up to oblivion and then I'll
actually be arrested for something I
actually did well hypothetically I'm
assuming that this kid is a piece of
[ __ ] he won't be why because you're
raising them so they're I don't want to
say it was my kid yeah it's your fault
it is but it won't be yeah sorry let me
live in this hypothetical world again
reasonable okay
my kid's gonna be [ __ ] decent but [ __ ]
that kid dude yeah wait did you mean
like mike is gonna be decent but also
[ __ ] that kid as in [ __ ] your kid like
that sometimes some things don't make
sense sometimes anger out and is making
sense in his head because childhood
anger coming out cuz I never did that
[ __ ] and that wasn't that great of a kid
how did you learn how to drive in the
first place though you think abouts a
really good question GTA he's probably
being taught by the mom like with like
incentive to drive because that's wrong
when I always thought at 13 but that's
cuz like older high school kids that
were like friends or whatever they let
me drive their van and they taught me
and that's crazy too because like that's
a clear sign that that kid isn't the
respect his parents I took my own car
one time but it was so dangerous I
wasn't allowed to well I was 15 and a
half so it wasn't any of my license yet
but it was gonna be my car once I got my
license and I'd already learned how to
drive and so it would just be at home
all day and we get home from school me
and my boyfriend and it was rainy and we
wanted orange chicken from the Chinese
place down the street and I was like
okay we can't walk their house raining
he convinced me to take the car and I
was so [ __ ] nervous cuz I never I
never break the rules or anything and I
knew like my dad would kill me if I
found out that I was driving without a
license and this lady this [ __ ] old
lady almost hit me
it was the rainy she just started
merging over lanes and into my car I was
like ah it was like this close and yeah
if I would have gotten caught so you
think I could no I wish I could go
explain to two teenagers that
one day you're gonna have your own car
and you're not even gonna want to go
anywhere I was like oh just [ __ ] drive
everywhere I'll take a cross-country
road trip
I've never road trip one time really oh
my soon as I got my license I drove
every yeah we went to Vegas so much the
first couple years yeah and we couldn't
even do anything in Vegas we just could
drive there I was all about driving and
now I'm like oh I don't want to drive
anywhere Hey
like let me post me that I want to go
people exactly yeah but then I'm so
stubborn I'm like my page seven [ __ ]
dollars for someone to come to my door
eat me while they hand me food like
somebody needs to do like a ride service
thing where it's just you pay a monthly
fee and then you can get X amount of
rides per day there'll be the sickest
[ __ ] ever called a personal driver yeah
yeah those are [ __ ] expensive you
know what else is the future whatever
[ __ ] expensive you're gonna pay like
it's like okay the bus okay you paid a
couple hundred bucks a month okay you
don't have to buy car insurance anymore
you pay a hundred bucks a month and you
could just have cars drive you places
and drop you off and then you pick up if
you want a nicer car you pay like 150 or
200 a month or whatever if you get
picked up and escalators yeah because if
we little drive itself if we don't have
a great public transportation system I
don't mind doing that because like I I
pay [ __ ] ton for the Tesla and I'm
pretty sure it would be cheaper like I
don't like a thousand bucks a month and
then you just get driven anywhere within
like a 30-mile radius
I don't worry about maintenance I would
question in this situation where the
automatic driving if someone throws up
in the car cuz they're drunk and then
the car comes to pick you up like does
the car know that it got thrown up in I
think it does it automatically cleans
the barbecue jettison oh just like the
pull of the public porta potti whatever
you know they after every use they spray
the whole thing down oh I didn't know
that
[Music]
[Music]